An algebraic inequality looks
like an algebraic equation but
it will have an inequality
sign instead of an equal sign.
These are the four inequality signs.
This inequality sign means less than.
This one means less than or equal to.
This one means greater than.
This one means greater than or equal to.
So for example,
if I were to write x is less then 3,
that's what it would look like.
And in words, it's x is less than 3.
If I write this, it means that
x is less than or equal to 3.
If I write this it means
that x is greater than 3.
And if I write this it means that
x is greater than or equal to 3.
Instead of having just one
solution like an equation.
The solution of an inequality
is a range of numbers.
Sometimes, an infinitely large range
make sure you have these
written down in your notebook.
Now let's focus on x is
less than 3 which means
x is any number that is less than 3.
Since there are infinitely
many values for x.
You will need to represent
the solution set for
this inequality on a number line.
We will begin by putting
an open circle on 3.
We are using an open circle to
indicate that 3 is an end point, but
not part of the solution set for
the inequality.
It's not part of the solution set
because 3 is not less than 3.
It's equal to 3.
The next step is to draw an arrow
over the part of the number line that
contains the numbers that
satisfy this inequality.
So that means we draw
the arrow to the left.
[BLANK_AUDIO]